[Applause]
it's so awesome to have you I'm so good
congratulations haven't cheered for you
a long time so that's so nice I'm a big
fan as well I want to talk about the
cover of your album this is adorable
wait let's see the cover this is you on
the album cover right yeah nine-year-old
Little Miss CH got look at you the horns
and the Halo were authentic yeah you
still got the boyish thing though the
horns and the Halo you were good that's
my son too I'm determined not to let the
12-year-old and me die me too no I think
that that's when you like stop growing
you stop really living like I'm total
child about you got to keep that
imagination yeah let go yeah we get so
serious as adults I love that so you're
you're named Killer Mike so where did
that come from I did not I would have
named me handsome Mike or yes I like it
I like it I had friends in rap you have
posies or friends boys just naturally
group together and do stinky stuff right
so yeah I'm I'm either you in the boy
scouts or you're a football player I was
good at none of that and so I found my
way with rapping and my friends were
like the best rappers in the world to me
and there was one battle they didn't
show if you guys you guys have seen
eight mile there was a battle rap and
and guys didn't guys didn't show up and
other guys were just attacking my guys
I'm like you know they're not there and
I got angry as a as a the kid in the
group and I just wrapped against
everybody and slashed them it was like a
Thor movie you used to fuel I love it
and was so impressed by that like that
off the cuff like that's incredible to
me I can't do it anymore but when I was
young it was amazing I could I could
never do it I was like I'm so impressed
it's a wonder I ever Remember lyrics
ever I got the name that night though a
guy stopped the party guy named Double D
and said he this kid's a killer and
after that no one ever called me just
Mike again it was Killer Mike that's
awesome so if you won grny but what if
what is being nominated by your peers
that's a different kind of thing what
does that mean for you yeah I I
currently have I have an altar for my
grandmother and my house and the Grammy
my first Grammy is broken because I kept
it at her house I dropped out of more
house and I told her in exchange for
dropping out not bring her a college
degree I was I gave her a Grammy she
said it still ain't no degree and um oh
she said next education care but she
kept it in her house and I remember
going to the house one day said mom mama
where's the Grammy I don't I don't see
it yeah and she put it in her closet I
said why is it in the closet now only
our familyes in the house she looked
around said cuz people
steal and I'm like I'm like but there
are people they still steal right she so
she apparently a week or two later she
dropped it and broke it and she was
ashamed to show me my sister told me to
you know talk to so I go and I talk to I
said let me see it and it's broken I
said Mom I love you I don't it's not so
I've never allowed the Grammys to repair
it but now it's time to get a you know
it's trying to get a few more to keep it
company look at that yeah just put a few
more up there family of gramy exctly I
like it and and and as an artist your
audience matter your fellow artist
matter but I'm not going to lie this
year getting rap album of the year will
mean everything in the world to me
because in the 50th year of hip-hop I've
I know for a fact I've made the greatest
representation of hip-hop this year I
love that certainty and that confidence
I've made I've made I've made something
that speaks to not only I grew up this
little nine-year-old chubby black kid in
this black Enclave in the Deep South but
I grew up influenced by this music that
was self-organized by kids kids in the
South Bronx self-organized around art
dance DJ you know graffiti mcing and
they created a way out and in my album
Honors that in a way that none of the
competition does and I love those guys
each of them are amazing remarkable yeah
but in my opinion and and in the opinion
of the people who are chiming in shouts
out to Charlamagne for doing that
there's no more cohesive album to me
that represents you know the 50 years of
hip-hop absolutely well let's do a
commercial break everybody the Grammy
nominated album Michael is out now find
it wherever you get your music go check
it out we'll be right back with some
more of our holiday gift guide you're
welcome in
[Music]
[Applause]
advance thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home